if i ask you brady what's one
plus two
plus three plus four and if i just keep
adding
forever what would you say the answer to
that would be well i would say
it would go it would tend towards
infinity
yeah that makes sense doesn't it
yeah am i right no it's minus
1 12.
it's negative
i've added all these positive numbers
together up to infinity
and i've got minus
a 12. and what's even more bizarre
is that this result is used in many
areas of physics in fact this result
is critical to getting the
26 dimensions of string theory to pop
out this result is critical in
understanding the casimir force
in quantum electrodynamics but i thought
what i would do today is we'd show a
proof of this result
that would be useful due to euler it
gets a little hairy but um if we just
hang in there we'll then
we'll do it together we'll go slowly
so so the way it begins with is to
rather than use these uh one plus two
plus three we use let's just think of
this series
1
plus x
plus x squared
plus x cubed
and just keep adding higher and higher
powers of x
and what we know is that this is equal
to 1 over 1 minus x that's the known
result in fact it's strictly true for x
less than unity so as it stands this is
this is uh it's limited
formally limited in its value we're
going to we're going to manipulate it a
little bit we're going to push the
boundaries at which we we're going to
use it we can either prove that now or
or if you want to accept it then
let's accept it let's accept it it's not
accepting that it's not a difficult
proof but we can accept it now we're
going to do something which
many of the number five viewers will
know about but some may not know we're
going to do something called we're going
to differentiate this and what that
means is we're going to work out that
what differentiation is
is working out the
rate of change
so for example if you know the distance
as a function of time and i
differentiate it it tells me the rate of
change of the distance or the velocity
so the rule that you need to know for
this is the the differentiation operator
is called d by dx
if it acts on
something like x to the n then the only
thing we need to know is that this gives
me brings down the n and it lowers the
power by one that's all we need to know
in order to be able to carry on so we do
it well the differential of one
is zero
the differential of x this is x to the
one so n is one so this brings down a
one
and that becomes x to the zero which is
1. so the first term is 1
x squared well i differentiate x squared
so n equals 2 here so it becomes 2 times
x
the next term is from x cubed so n is 3
so this becomes 3x squared okay so you
get the idea the next term would be 4x
cubed for example
and this equals and and
you'll have to just
accept my word for it at the moment the
right hand side when i differentiate it
just becomes 1 over 1 minus x squared
now what i'm going to do
is i'm going to set
x
to be equal to -1
all right this is what euler did you
just do what do you mean you're just
going to do that yeah well i'm just
going to fit it into this see what it
tells me this formula is going to give
me
so what does it give me it gives me 1
minus 2
because of x is minus 1 plus 3 because x
x squared is positive
minus 4
plus
5 etc minus
and if i set x equal to minus 1 here it
becomes 1 over 2 squared so this is a
quarter
so this is already beginning to look a
little strange hang on this seems
significant so what have we just shown
we've just shown
that 1 minus 2 plus 3 minus 4 plus 5
minus 6 plus 7 is equal all the way up
to infinity
is equal to a quarter i'm now going to
introduce i think one of the best
functions ever
okay and i'm sure we're going to be
seeing a lot of it in that number file
of the next
few months maybe and it was first
introduced i think by euler
and then it was generalized by riemann
and it plays a huge role in
understanding the distribution of prime
numbers and it will play a huge role in
verifying this calculation okay
it's called the riemann
zeta function sometimes called the euler
riemann zeta function
and its definition is the following it's
got a funny symbol
so it's it's got a symbol zeta
and the the argument of it is called s
and its definition
is it's the infinite sum so i'm going to
sum
from
of the integers from n equals one to
infinity
of 1
over
n to the s okay so what what is this
this is
1 well let me just
1 over 1 to the s well that's just 1
plus 1 over 2 to the s
plus 1 over 3 to the s
plus 1 over 4 etc now euler he said that
s was real right it was a it was a
regular number along the real axis
what riemann did
and i'll just
quote it here
for now is that he allowed s
to be
made up of a real part which we'll call
sigma
plus an imaginary path which we'll call
t
so this is a complex okay so this is
this is the difference between euler's
approach and riemann riemann generalized
euler you can see sigma is the real bit
and then t is the complex bit this is
called
and it's an imaginary number because
it's i times t and together they form a
complex number
we're going to concentrate on the real
bit here what euler now did he
multiplies this by
uh 2 to the minus s
times zeta
of s okay
so what is that
so this is just
2 to the minus s
plus
another way of writing 1 over 2 to the s
is 2 to the minus s
so this is equal to plus
4
to the minus s
plus this is
here this is 3 to the minus s times 2 to
the minus s gives me 6 to the minus
plus eight to the minus s
plus all the way up
okay so he just multiplied this
zeta by by this so what euler now did
was he it he takes two of these
away from this
okay okay
so let me just write it out slowly so
let me just write out the first term
which is the zeta so it's
1
plus
2 to the minus s
plus 3 to the minus s
plus 4 to the minus s plus
etc
and now if i
take away
this
twice this thing
i get um
the first thing i get is so i'm taking
away minus two
lots of
and i'm going to
line these up okay i'm lining the two up
there i'm going to line the 4 up there
and then i would line the 6 up you know
with the matching the 6 so
but now what you can see
so the 1 just lives by itself that's ok
i've got 2 to the minus s minus 2 lots
of them so this is gives me minus
2 to the minus s
the 3 is by itself so that just stays as
it
is four minus two lots of four gives me
minus one lot of four
so you can see i'm beginning to
alternate okay
and
i need some more paper brady
all right
i'll get you
so now what he does
as he did above there when he set x
equal to minus one he sets s
equal to minus one okay and now let's
just ask what what does this expression
look like
so on the left hand side here when we do
that we've got
1 minus
2 times 2 to the minus
minus minus 1 which is plus 1 so it's 1
minus 4
which is minus 3.
okay
but what is zeta of minus 1
well if i look up here and put s equals
to minus 1 in here can you see that this
becomes 1 plus 2 plus 3 plus 4
etc
so
all the way up forever
and now
on the right hand side
so i've done the left hand side on the
right hand side i do the same i set s
equal to minus one and you can see what
i've got here is one
minus two
plus three
minus four
plus five etc
but he's already shown what that is
if we look here
we've already seen that one minus two
plus three minus four plus five is a
quarter
and i divide out by the three minus
three and i get that one
plus two
plus three
plus four
plus
is actually equal
to minus the twelfth
and that is the euler
proof
in quotation marks that the sum of the
integers
is minus the twelfth
and the so it sounds crazy right it does
a bit it sounds crazy and
what what you can do
and what uh riemann was able to show
is that this actually makes sense
when you look
at the riemann function the riemann zeta
function
the complex version of it
and set s equals to
minus one
he showed that zeta of minus one indeed
is equal
to -12
and i think a a way of understanding
that uh what's going on here is that
when you look at it in terms of the
riemann zeta function there is actually
a
it diverges at one point the riemann
zeta function
and that one point is when s
equals one
so zeta so remember what zeta
um
so
zeta of s
we said
was 1
plus 1 over
2 to the s plus 1 over 3 to the s etc
so if i set s
equal to one
then zeta of one
is one plus a half
plus a third
plus a quarter
and this is a very slowly diverging
series this tends
to infinity
and i think one way of kind of trying to
understand why it is
that
the
the actual riemann zeta function which
we may describe in more detail when we
come to think about the primes why zeta
of -1
is equal to minus a 12.
the reason why this is is
uh consistent with the fact that we
actually think when we sum over the
integers they're actually infinite
is that in in some way we're having to
go through
this point here
and what riemann is able to demonstrate
is by
kind of circumventing it which is the
the physical way of of saying
removing the divergence we can end up
with these sensible numbers like minus a
12. so professor
i mean the question i have is
if i sat down with a calculator and
wrote one plus two plus three plus four
plus five and did it forever
and then press the equal sign
am i going to get minus a twelve you see
i
i don't know
in reality
one of the things you have to be careful
about here that we have to be careful
about is
that that what you have just stated
there is basically using the set of
axioms that we that we're used to in in
this in in the context of finite sums
these aren't finite these are infinite
sums so in other words you could you
could keep going to the end of the
universe typing in the numbers and you'd
still have made epsilon contribution to
this overall sum
and and that means really small really
small and and i think that
hidden in there is a subtlety of you've
got to deal with divergent numbers
divergence sums very carefully and so
the logic which goes in
to
show that you know something is clearly
divergent
um
as you were just saying that with it
with the putting it into the calculator
doesn't necessarily follow when you're
really dealing with these divergent sums
you have to be very careful as to
understand where the divergence is
emerging and i think this is an example
of of a case where this riemann zeta
function is perfectly well
behaved at zeta of minus one
and it's it's
it's
it's called an analytic continuation
it's taking you from one regime where it
clearly looks like it's divergent and
moving it into a regime where it's
better defined
i can accept that
zero is a number of some significance
and that one is
and that infinity although it's not a
number is a significant thing
and i can accept pi
and e
but minus a twelfth just seems so
oh yeah i know but
but it does play a
play a role in lots of different things
does that the number 12 and and it's so
for example as i said the
the calculations of the critical
dimension in string theory the 26
dimensions
comes from this calculation in fact it's
basically
the strings live in a two-dimensional
move in a two-dimensional plane
and and then they've got orthogonal
directions and there's 24 of these
orthogonal directions which is 2 times
12 and and that's this calculation is
where
and
you actually get the the critical number
of dimensions it gives me the 24. and
there's a wonderful
mathematician called john
bays or
buyers let me just write him down and
people might want to go and look up some
of his work he's he's he's given
seminars
on the importance of uh 24
and 8
and it's used in all sorts of different
packing formulas
it appears all over
first let's let's go back and look at
this and why is this answer seemingly on
one level ridiculous well let's look at
the the first n um integers that first
natural numbers so we actually do the
sum
one to n
so you go one plus two
plus three
all the way up to n
okay
right
now we know the answer to this
it's
n
n plus one
divided by two i don't want to emphasize
here this is called this here that i've
written down here is that is the partial
sum this is the nth partial sum clearly
as i take n to infinity
this number's just getting bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger i should be
getting the answer
infinity
but of course you know infinity doesn't
really exist in nature does it you know
you don't measure an infinity in nature
you just don't do that but you can
attach a value to this sum
you can attach a number to the sum and
it's unique
and uh there's various ways in which you
can do that one way is um
this is a special case of the riemann
zeta function so what is the riemann
zeta function the riemann zeta function
is the following
define like so
it's the sum
from n equals one to infinity
of
n to the minus z
okay
so
if z is bigger than one
this sum is perfectly well defined it
gives a nice finite answer so you're
basically just taking numbers that get
smaller and smaller and smaller and
smaller and adding them together
okay it's intuitively feasible that you
would get a finite answer from that
so from z greater than one
you get this
now what you do is you do something very
important you do this trick of analytic
continuation that's what it's called
basically you know that you have you
have this this formula
so you have some expression for this
this sum that works for z greater than
one
and then you say okay let's assume that
that expression also works
for different values of z where it's not
greater than one where it's less than
one i'm saying
and actually
assuming that the the functions that
you're talking about have very
special properties and then they're
analytic that means that all their
their continuous functions that they're
nice and smooth there's no kinks or
anything like that assuming that holds
then you can make this extension when
you take the analytic continuation of
the riemann zeta function and you
evaluate it at minus one i could i chose
minus one because when i plug in minus
one i just get the sum from n equals one
to infinity of n which is precisely this
sum here
okay
so minus one
well i do the analytic continuation i
plug it into my nice formula that i
derived for z greater than one but i now
apply it to z less than less than one
and i get minus twelve
okay
through this process of analytic
continuation
now you're probably still skeptical not
really believing that this works but
but we can prove it without doing this
okay just to show that we can there are
ways to get to this there's loads of
ways you can get to this answer okay
this is the sort of the classic way
using this riemann z to function an
analytic continuation uh but there are a
million ways to do this
okay so shall we just prove it yeah
let's let's just so say more paper yep
when in physics do you need to know what
one plus two plus three plus four plus
five plus six plus seven
et cetera well okay so so um
essentially in physics what you do is um
okay so we saw one example right in in
particular string theory book where he
was trying to predict the dimensionality
of the of the universe
and uh
actually this sum appears because you
end up having to sum up all different
you can think of a string right an
actual the strings that build string
theory are built from
they have different modes of oscillation
they have the sort of single one first
harmonic second harmonic third harmonic
and so on and so on you have an infinite
number of harmonics and you have to sum
up all their contributions
and when you sum up all their
contributions and naively you would get
an infinite answer but actually no you
don't you get
minus a 12
appearing and that's the actually the
minus the 12 that then feeds back into
26. and dimensions but it's not just in
string theory it's it's these kinds of
sums which naively are p and integrals
as well the integral is just a
continuous sum these kind of divergent
sums divergent integrals
they they appear all over all over
quantum field theory where you have
seemingly infinite contributions but you
can regulate them you can make sense of
that infinity
and there and the answer is how you make
sense of that affinity should not affect
the answer and indeed it doesn't and the
certain properties of sums that that you
can that you can they have to satisfy
certain theorems and whatnot so that
they do make sense that they do give you
unique answers some sums just are too
crazy but certainly ones like this are
totally totally nice and you can get
nice finite answers out of them